let's talk about the sequence that's
like about
45 minutes into the film when
sienna and diego's characters
they go back in time they're going to
see the fortune teller and then they get
into the fight
and diego is sort of saying like you
can't prove that
this happened and then they go out into
the street and they get into
an even bigger fight and then it
transitions to the lights outside of
lacma
i think the the first thing to mention
is the idea of
uh adrian and matteo sort of
narrativizing their own
memories and sort of negotiating them
with each other
happened really on in the development of
the script
i think that it's actually sort of a
normal thing to do in the theater world
where you turn aside to the audience and
sort of
you know say what you're thinking or
what's happening for you
that you might not say to all the
characters on the stage
i think the other part of it is early on
in my career someone told me that films
are really for external adventures
and internal stories should really be
reserved for novels uh
and i thought that was insane it seemed
to me like
film is the perfect way to find a way to
externalize someone's internal journey
and to get into somebody's head
and and to see what that that person was
sort of how they were clicking
so in the scene here um adrian and
matteo
uh this is sort of where adrian is is
taking back the narrative mateo has told
her i'm going to make sense of your head
and he's sort of trying to put
everything in order and her head is not
in order and so her memories she starts
sort of diving from memory to memory to
memory
um and and i think the the challenge
once we got it on its feet was
how the hell do you do that and i think
our week of rehearsal was really key to
that
don't you think guys in terms of like
marking those moments
where you were turning to one another
and then there was like a
click or a pause or a blink just some
moment of transition from we're in the
scene where we're living in this past
memory and now we're
talking about what we think about that
past memory it was one of those things
that you read in a script and you're
like oh i love this like you know
i think in the eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind they sort of play with the
same thing where you're in a scene and
then
they're kind of narrating the experience
from the past or future or whatever it
may be and it's it's the kind of thing
that i
when i was reading the script that i
loved and then in reality when it came
to doing it
i remember me and you were like how do
you sell this how do you kind of
you're in one moment and then and then
those shifts those kind of hairpin turns
were so
complex but it required a lot of
a lot of faith and a lot of just it's
just not normal life it's
it was so um it's so sort of against
your instinct to do that but
but so successful in the edit obviously
i think the the the reference
tyra made is is important because i i
did read the script and i was thinking
of
theater and i was thinking how many
times in theater you've done that
but obviously it's it's very different
to act in theater than on a film
set and and i guess uh i i didn't
realize
the the size of the challenge we had in
front of us when i read the script
you know i did too like enjoyed it and i
said this is perfect and then
when i started breaking up into pieces
the whole thing it was like this makes
no sense how can you
do that and and i guess it's because
it's not a narration
to me you know it's just like you you're
living two different realities in
two different levels but uh both have a
very specific intention
and uh and i guess when you read it you
you think you're living in one reality
till you find out
no i'm supposed to play two and i'm
supposed to be
clear in those two intentions and they
can't conflict with each other
so often i feel like in movies you know
you know whether it's something like
blue valentine which deals with memory
and it deals with like the past and the
present but you're telling those stories
separately
what i loved about this was the
interweaving of that
narrative where you're telling those two
time periods
in the same scene it's really to me was
like it's so dramatic and engaging to
watch
i love the negotiation as well between
the two of them and how
the rival kind of memories of what
actually happens in a moment which is
which is i think of a conversation that
everybody has had with their partner at
some point it was like no
you didn't do that you did this and
everybody's so convinced of their own
reality
to play those out with each other in
real time was such an interesting thing
to explore
i think it's such a testament to you
both how we did have such specific plans
right like oh we have to the camera has
to be here so we can wipe this way or
you know i need you to look this way so
that we can motivate this transition and
and often i think you know it was such
deeply emotional
big lifting that you were doing so to
have that on top of it
um and that you navigated it so so
effortlessly i mean it was it was just a
real testament to the professionalism
that you know it wasn't just getting
lost in a scene it was like getting lost
in a scene
giving these incredible emotional
performances and then also letting me
like chase a camera around you to get
into this transition that we needed
to let the camera also tell part of that
story and it was a huge challenge
that you really stepped up to in a
beautiful way and it's a challenge for
audiences i mean
as as it is a challenge for for us
because to to maintain the emotional
connection with characters that are
jumping in and out
uh you know and and not to become
cynical
about the emotion you know it's it's not
an easy one
and it was from my side always fear
to fall into that and uh when you see it
happening
which there's also some kind of magic
going on that you can't say you
controlled all of that
i mean the uh and and when i saw it with
an audience for the first time
it was such a relief because he was so
risky
i think and i think especially you know
talking about this sort of
internalization
to try to get into the head of a
character who's in a concussed state
and whether that's like you know i
wanted to parallel the the sense of a
concussion with the psychosis of grief
and how those two things are so similar
and what our brains do to protect us
from
uh what we can't handle um but but
being able to let go as an audience
member and trust
that the movie is taking you somewhere
that that
might be a little uncomfortable but is
taking you somewhere good
ultimately um i think that's sort of the
key for this movie
it is really a ride you know the more
you resist it's sort of the message of
the movie it's like the more you resist
the less it works you know it's very
complicated to keep it all
straight and so it required a very
concentrated prep
with tara really talking through the
script
and where she envisioned it all since
she was the creator
where she envisioned all those sequences
belong
and where all those lines belonged and
and and where the emotion was coming
from and i think that
concentrated period was what we really
benefited from
because when we got on set even there
were there was always a question
you know everybody had questions about
wait where does
where is this and when is this and the
same thing with the actors obviously
but luckily we had katie and carolina
there too uh who were mind-melding
with tara and really understood the
sequences
we had to create like a really cool team
to pull all this off
i'm really into like you know
explorations of consciousness and
perception and i'm really into like you
know
talking about philosophy with my
collaborators and
and i think this project like we all got
to do a lot of that
and so there was a lot of really
difficult things that we were up against
of like you know how to make some of
these transitions happen
um and instead of like having real
clear-cut ideas of how they would happen
we kind of we
we approached it all super organically
um
and i think through like having a lot of
these conversations
um my dear friend is the vfx supervisor
on it
and with carolina and with tara like we
just kind of brainstorm like seven
different ways to achieve
the transition um and so like
it's kind of with this movie i felt like
because we had such a
playful and trusting creative team
we could we could start with chaos and
like
reach something really beautiful
together you know i thought that that
was
a really powerful way to deal with those
transitions
and i mean somebody was talking about
the team and gathering the team that was
so important as well
with my team the camera team because
they were keeping like reports
on like the speed of a pen from one
scene to another and we had like this
long like tag sheet that basically had
all the information and then brian had
to recreate the like
same little movement and not having all
those toys like how to make all those
big transitions
with the tools that we had i think this
sequence in particular
i remember the first time you know the
second time i read the script
there are two or three sequences i mean
the car accident for sure
and this was one that i was just like
wow this is like a big
meal right and um i
it was one of the things as well that
wanted me to do this movie because
how many movies i mean i haven't seen
movies like this before
and i thought it was just like such a
great challenge to be proud of
um and i think for all the transition
sequences
i mean that this one in particular
because it goes for so many different
moments in different locations
and different um day and night so like
different lighting setups
but i think the most important thing was
always to respect
um the characters like how they would
transition
emotionally from one world to another
right and then the technique
whatever it is just comes to support
that right so the audience never feels
strict because it can become like a
gimmicky thing
because it's cool right to do all these
like cool transitions and stuff
and tara wanted to go away from that and
really just
take the audience in that journey as
they were feeling it and and i think
that was you know even bigger challenge
in that sense right because the
technique
has to follow um that idea
yeah i mean i think certainly we talked
about the seamlessness of wanting all of
the transitions not to be
in the way right to be like in service
of where adrian was going and where
mateo was going um but you know there
was like so much i think when you work
with um
like technical team key you know key
team members
everybody wants to show you what they
can do so it's like oh check out this
amazing special effects sound i have or
look at how cool we can make this like
shadow thing crawl up all over the place
and it was a lot of no no less
less less less less like everything had
to feel as grounded as possible
as um real as possible as minimal as
possible
so that we were still focused on these
characters it was never meant to be
showy and i think it is a beautiful
balance that this movie achieves and
this sequence is like a big piece of it
is be grounded in reality and how to
make it magical right it's just
that it's not like just oh surrealism
and then we're just like walking from
one
um world to another like an asset trip
and it's not that right these two like
very grounded with the real emotions
um of adrienne and and what she was
going through right in the relationship
black mind that sense plays a huge part
of it because it does make
it very magical and it's also like la it
is a character in the movie
you know and it was always important for
terror right and to start
above it's not usually what you see
right in the pictures of of the
installation i like my right is usually
from the ground so it does give this
i don't know it's like it lifts right um
it gives air and like a different
sensation
and i remember if i recall that was sort
of the last shot of the night right
we went and we didn't think we were
going to make it we didn't think we were
going to be able to get that shot
it was like and i remember just feeling
really
like it was a very important shot to
have and get this perspective
that nobody else got of that of that
light installation
really be you know come come at it from
a different point of view
and it really helps the sequence makes
the sequence and i'm glad we
were able to get it i know we were sort
of up against time with lacma with
you know our day etcetera yeah yeah that
and also although like
that holds that lacma and artist rights
society
like i learned dealing with them like if
you cry a little
like if you just cry a little bit like
people will help you
you know with the production design
we used tara's house which felt like it
was really
important and to use because that's a
place that tara like you know has spent
a lot of time
and and that these places were very um
personal
and i felt that we were all going on
this journey
of revisiting this traumatic situation
with her
and so to be her creative army that
could kind of kind of come in and
and and relive this moment with her and
experience the confusion
firsthand with her and and realize that
like
through chaos we could achieve something
that like is
unique yeah i think i think the process
all along the way
we just would joke you have to sort of
get like into that concussed state into
the wand or darkly mindset which we all
were i started on set
in this like kind of a little bit
untethered
feeling and that was sort of where each
member of the team had to come with me
just was like a process of
it's going to be great it's going to be
great and trying to slowly but surely
explain it
we've gotten some feedback recently some
women have been like i really loved the
movie it reminds me of like a marriage
story from like a female perspective
and she did sort of surround herself
with
um a bunch of women that maybe do occupy
a space of not just like occupying
femininity but
a a great mix of femininity and
masculinity
and it and it does it does seem to have
sort of
made its way through the film and and
touching audiences not that it's only
touching
women audiences but that audiences are
saying
they can feel that it's through the sort
of point of view of a kind of
female lens which i do think is
interesting because
i don't think that there are a lot of
movies that you can
point to like even when i even when you
make the reference of eternal sunshine
or some of the other movies um actually
are distinctly
from a male point of view and this is
not that
this movie falls into that category of
you know why any of us
are drawn to making certain kinds of
movies is that
you know what what makes it unique on
the page
um is feeling like oh oh i i haven't
seen this before this feels like a risk
and that that to me like some of my
favorite movies
um that i've been involved in or that
i've watched and and you know are the
ones where you feel like
gosh i wonder if anybody i wonder how
the heck this ever got
like greenlit who decided to make this
movie and i and i feel like again some
of my
my my best experiences have been like
this one they've been
looking at a script and feeling like i i
believe this can be something
special but but it but but it's such a
risk because you just don't know if it's
going to actually work and then seeing
it work and it's getting to have that
experience with the audience and knowing
that that
that everybody achieved what was set out
is
it's like it's like the best feeling and
the reason to make
for me the reason to make to make movies